we all have that one toy from our
childhood we held near and dear to our
hearts from stuffed bears to action
figures every child has something
meaningful to them that they clung to it
may have been a gift from a parent or
grandparent or maybe it was an old
family memento passed down from
generation to generation regardless
those of us who have these toys became
extremely connected to them physically
and emotionally perhaps you talked to
this toy like it was your friend or
clung to it during nights where it was
storming in order to comfort yourself
what if these toys were giving the same
feelings back towards us and we didn't
realize it it's a question that only
those in the universe of the scp
foundation could find a proper answer to
scp-174
ventriloquist's dummy it was a normal
day for scp-174
and its owner marian nine-year-old girl
had a pretty ordinary existence for a
girl her age
a room decorated in pink and obvious
fashion her school books and art
supplies sat on her little desk in the
corner and all of her dolls and toys
neatly sat on the shelves on the wall
she wakes up around eight o'clock for
her third grade classes at the nearby
elementary school where she is driven to
by her father every day she gets dressed
quickly in her school uniform
scp-174 remembers a long blue skirt
white button-up shirt and flat black
shoes this was routine
scp-174 watched her every day to the
point it became part of its expected
daily regimen mary ventures out of the
room with a quick goodbye to all her
lovely toys
scp-174 being among her favorites if not
her absolute favorite toy to play with
for hours scp-174 would sit on the
shelves of mary's room staring at the
same pink wall all day long waiting in
pure excitement and happiness for the
room door to get pushed back open so
playtime can begin once again mary loved
the toy and oddly enough the toy loved
mary back most kids would probably find
scp-174 creepy ventriloquist's dummies
are not often thought of as cute or
cuddly or even good playtime friends but
mary didn't care she and scp-174 had so
much fun together that she didn't even
comprehend the fact that it might be
creepy never mind a thought about what
other people might think all the
dressing up making up stories and living
them out from brave princes saving
princesses to evil dragons or pirates
taking on the seven seas in search of
treasures
scp-174 had fun playing along with
mary's childhood imagination her joy was
its joy it was more than enough for mary
to be happy and in turn scp-175
was also happy it remembers the day it
was brought out of the dingy attic where
it was forgotten left to dust and
cobwebs to pile up on it over time
scp-174 was a creation of mary's
grandfather a now retired ventriloquist
performer and a master of it at that
scp-174 didn't mind the work but it
wasn't loved like it was now it was just
a prop to be used for laughs and money
but now it was something someone
actually cared about the glorious
afternoon when mary discovered him in a
storage bin was a day it wouldn't forget
as it now felt loved and appreciated by
someone mary didn't want money out of
scp-174
nor did she want fame she just wanted a
friend and scp-174 was going to give as
much as it could to her as mary grew
older it seemed playtime had become
rarer and rarer it went from multiple
times a day to once or maybe twice a
night on a good day to once a week and
now mary a 16 year old girl didn't look
like she had the time anymore books and
papers piled up on her bed from nights
of studying her attention was grabbed by
her cell phone and late night calls with
her friends and on the weekends when her
and scp-174 would usually spend the most
time together in the past she wasn't
even in the house anymore never mind in
a room and by the time she came back she
was too tired to want to do anything she
didn't talk to it anymore and barely
even looked at it at most scp-174 would
receive a passing glance and a weak
smile but at least she still knew it was
there and that for what it was was
enough for scp-174 to be content two
more years passed and now mary was 18.
she had grown up so much as cp 174
thought to itself it was a cool day as
the dusk of summer was upon mary's city
august was coming to a close and autumn
was steadily creeping up on them but for
some reason mary hadn't been preparing
for school there was no backpack instead
of a variety of suitcases and bins lined
her room taking up most of the space
that was previously empty clothes
hangers lay on her bed and mary's mother
was organizing her clothes into two
piles it looked like mary was moving out
but that wasn't true right she's never
left without her playmate and her best
friend right after two days of packing
and preparing it seemed mary was ready
to leave to wherever she was going
scp-174 hoped it wasn't going to be for
too long perhaps it's a vacation or a
short school field trip had thought but
the fateful day of mary's departure had
arrived the room was completely cleared
out and other than her pink walls and
floral comforter almost everything was
gone mary popped back into the room
suitcase in hand looked around and left
without a word no goodbye she didn't
even look at scp-174
scp-174 was devastated months passed
without a sign of mary scp-174 heard
phones ringing in faint whispers of her
voice through telephone lines but it
wasn't enough scp-174
missed its friend on one fateful night
scp-174 was met with rings and alarms
the house's fire alarm system smoke
permeated the air and it began to grow
warmer and warmer than hotter than so
hot it couldn't bear the pain all
scp-174 could do was sit there and wait
for someone something to save it but no
one came
scp-174 woke up wet and charred under a
pile of dirt ash and wood it could spot
daylight through the cracks and crevices
of the mound that pinned it down it laid
there for what felt like hours before it
heard a familiar voice mom dad the voice
was met with sobering responses hello
sweetie and sorry you had to see this we
don't know what happened it was mary
back from wherever she went and her
family was here now they could all be
back together scp-174 thought we have a
few things that survive the fire your
pile is over there mary's mother said
it's not much but at least it's
something footsteps grew louder towards
scp-174
the pile above it grew lighter and
lighter as the face of its best friend
came clearer and clearer into view
scp-174 wasn't met with a face of
happiness or joy like it expected more
one of fear and disgust do you see
anything her father asked nothing i want
mary responded coldly before leaving the
pile all
scp-174 wanted was a friend someone it
could care for and would care for it it
tried its best but now it guessed that
all meant nothing to marry
scp-174 closed its eyes and with a
gut-wrenching feeling of despair listen
to the voice of its former best friends
slowly fade away it was a few days
months years or even decades before
scp-174 reawoke it wasn't with a new
loving family or in the room of a child
who might play with it again now this
was not where it was it was in a cold
locker with its only light being from
the slits of the locked door that kept
it contained sadness was all that
scp-174 could feel and it's all anyone
around as cp-174 could feel it's sadness
was so powerful it was influencing those
around it to pity it maybe then they'd
play with it but there is no playing in
what scp-174 would learn to be the scp
foundation the scp foundation conducted
its standard amount of research on the
anomaly they asked the same questions
they always did what object class do we
give this anomaly initially they gave it
safe it would stay in a box and they
didn't have to watch it plus it didn't
pose a reasonable amount of danger but
would the scp foundation be correct in
its assessment of the object class
scp-174 was marked as a safe class low
security object up until may 14th 2013.
this was a special day for scp-174 well
not exactly for 174 but for mary it was
mary's 19th birthday but scp-174 was not
there to wish her that its sadness grew
and grew maybe if it was there for her
she would love it again maybe if it was
there on this day they could play again
just once just one more time they could
be friends again and scp-174 could be
happy again with all its strength
scp-174 moved itself for the first time
a doctor later discovered scp-174
sitting on the floor next to its
containment unit looking directly at the
main entrance door the doctor hastily
placed scp-174 back into its storage
locker and later the foundation would
install surveillance cameras
scp-174 watched the entire process
through the slits in its storage locker
even more discouraging the foundation
also implanted as cp-174 with a tracking
device all hope was lost for scp-174 to
see mary again but it couldn't forget
her no matter how hard it tried it grew
sadder and sadder to understand scp-174
better we need to take a look at the scp
foundation's file on
scp-174
scp-174 is a wooden ventriloquist's
dummy with severe damage seen on the
figure as cp-174 has a number of
anomalous properties could it be that
scp-174 sadness and grief over losing
its friend was so great that scp-174
developed these properties it's possible
but the scp foundation is still unsure
when viewed in a person's peripheral
vision it has been reported that scp-174
will look at them with an expression of
longing or sadness in general anyone in
the vicinity of scp-174 will grow sad or
direct sympathy at scp-174
the scp foundation later discovered that
anyone who places
scp-174 on their hand feels the urge to
talk to the entity those who have put
scp-174 on their hand will report to
researchers that all scp-174 wants is a
friend that it could talk to those who
wear scp-174 for longer periods of time
will begin speaking in a high-pitched
childlike voice the foundation believes
that this is the voice of scp-174
now changing the roles of ventriloquist
and ventriloquist dummy as the person
wearing scp-174 is the dummy the subject
will begin to converse with itself
through their own voice and
scp-174 in all cases 174 will tell its
wearer that it was abandoned and left to
the trash by mary it would tell them how
much it missed mary how sad it was and
how angry it was getting
scp-174 learned quickly how easy it
could trick these people into feeling
bad for it it went from telling the
truth about what happened to it to
changing its story over and over again
to the point that the scp foundation has
no idea what the true story is and they
have no idea about mary stories of being
left at a playground to being thrown out
or left on a stage by a performer began
to become commonplace anything as cp-174
could think of it would use to
manipulate the person wearing it
scp-174 knows the truth however but
maybe it's easier for it to lie and
forget the trauma it experienced is it
possible that scp-174 is becoming
corrupted in a way it was also learned
that scp-174's fake stories about its
past will have a direct connection to
the subject that is wearing it so if you
remember a time you might have been
bullied as a child or lost a toy or
anything that might have been something
negative
scp-174 will use that for its own
sympathy the loss of its first owner has
completely changed scp-174's outlook on
life and now it wants to make a friend
by any means necessary even manipulation
through anomalous means scp-174
developed a series of telepathic
abilities to further its manipulation
for sympathy a d-class was ordered to
wear 174 the doll's burned and battered
appearance left the d-class hesitant doc
you sure i have to wear this creepy
thing please proceed with the test
d-14285
the doctor responded coldly we know the
foundation is okay with putting morals
aside for their tests so this answer
should have been obvious to the d-class
personnel
d-14285 lifted scp-174 and placed it on
her right hand and a conversation with
the anomaly began what happened to you
d-14285 asked quietly there was a fire
d-14285 said in the high-pitched voice
mimicking scp-174 i was at home with the
performer they used to own me the
d-class said almost on the verge of
tears there were burglars they broke
into our house
my house and began to steal anything
valuable they saw
back in her normal voice d14285
responded that that happened to my
family i'm so sorry to hear that you
don't deserve that she said in her
high-pitched voice the burglars they
were stealing everything gold and
jewelry money pictures even pieces of
art my owner painted all the memories he
made were being stolen
my father was an artist
d14285 said in her normal voice they
said fire do everything to cover their
tracks all of us were burned but i was
the only one who lived the performer who
owned me died trying to rescue me the
d-class says in the voice of scp-174
he was trying to save me but
but the flames they
they consumed him
now
now i i have no friends anymore
really will you will you be my friend
d14285 breaks down into tears and
returns to her normal voice i'm sorry
she says through sobs i i'm so sorry oh
i'll be your friend the observing
researcher begins to yell cancel the
test immediately there's clearly
something more going on here guards
enter the testing chamber upon the
researchers orders and begin to restrain
d14285 and remove the manipulative
anomaly from her arm the d-class begins
to scream and cry no no they took her
from me my baby she begins to fight
against the restraining security guards
but is dragged out kicking and screaming
while calling for scp-174
who lays motionless in the corner of the
testing chamber it was found that
b-class amnestics were effective in
quelling the lingering effects of
scp-174
however if left untreated those affected
by scp-174's influence and manipulation
are similar in behavior to those of
mothers separated from their children
sadly the test that led to the discovery
of amnestics being useful in stopping
manipulative effects were found after
d-14285's test as she was terminated due
to her not being able to be consoled and
her cries constantly being disruptive
before her termination the foundation
found a number of abnormalities in her
behavior
d14285 would only ever talk about
scp-174
regardless of topic of conversation or
questions asked to her she would only
respond with the same frantic line of
questions or statements is is the doll
okay can i see him what did you do to
him why won't you let me see him i was
supposed to be friends with him please
let me please tell me he's all right
this effect does not persist as it
normally goes away after a few hours or
days but in some cases like d-14285
this effect will endure to the point of
obsession and depression as such
scp-174's object class has been changed
to a euclid level anomaly the scp
foundation deals with anomalies of
varying danger and containment
difficulty we are familiar with ones
that look dangerous and act even more
dangerous from scp-096 the shy guy to
the employees of scp-3008 the infinite
ikea or even scp-049 the plague doctor
and its touch of death but what might be
even more dangerous is when the scp
foundation discovers an anomaly that
does not look dangerous in the slightest
perhaps that's why they initially placed
an extremely manipulative and dangerous
anomaly into safe class storage the scp
foundation is known for its cold tactics
and cruel experiments but in the case of
scp-174
it was extremely important to test the
anomaly in order to know how dangerous
it really was
scp-174 is the story of a toy that was
held near and dear during childhood
similar to the ones we can all
potentially have the play times and
childhood innocence carried those bonds
deeper than we may think in the case of
scp-174 it was used during this period
then pushed aside once its former friend
mary grew up and had to focus on her
life outside of the world of imagination
this turned scp-174 into a cold monster
who wants that connection and bond back
by any means necessary it puppeteers
people in order to get sympathy
manipulating them by using their own
traumatic stories against them in a sick
twisted attempt to make what it thinks a
friend is if you happen to still have
your favorite childhood toy laying
around somewhere in your house it might
be a good idea to go show it some love
like literally go grab that tickle me
elmo or hannah montana singing doll and
give it a hug tell it it's still
appreciated for all the fun times
because well there may be consequences
to your actions or lack thereof now go
check out scp-066 eric's toy or scp-3108
the nerfing gun for more anomalous toys
you just can't get enough of or that
just can't get enough of you